I still needed.
NOTE CONF
Makes not needed.
Needed.
NOTE CONF
What's going on?
Ok, um why isn't this doing its thing?
NOTE CONF
Laptop crazy?
I had previews working are projecting.
NOTE CONF
Why aren't you projecting now?
You are predicting Mike's not doing anything.
NOTE CONF
Now that's trying.
Let's try this one.
NOTE CONF
Oh, that one's working.
OK, Where you at?
NOTE CONF
Noisy ass thing.
All right, so the question was when I'm making So
NOTE CONF
let's, uh let's bring up the assignment, Alright?
Look at that.
NOTE CONF
Seven new posts.
Are they all asking the same thing?
NOTE CONF
Maybe.
Um Ok, so we were asking about the type of
NOTE CONF
loop, right?
So string loop, which is a loop V, an identifier
NOTE CONF
in an expression.
So what?
NOTE CONF
Remind me what the question was.
So we're expecting the expression to be straight.
NOTE CONF
The expression we also have.
Ah, yes.
NOTE CONF
OK, So what happens with the expression being a string?
And the reason I want to talk about this is
NOTE CONF
this goes a bit deeply into what locks tends to
do in other places.
NOTE CONF
So that's what I want to recommend for you is
you consider what locks does in other places.
NOTE CONF
So I'm gonna bring up a few examples, so Oh,
wow.
NOTE CONF
Another example we saw was the method calls in a
method called the grammar.
NOTE CONF
Actually says expression, parentheses, arguments, parenthesis, Am I right?
Someone else has to look cos my computer's jammed up
NOTE CONF
when we did function calling What was the parsing expression
that we used to grandma?
NOTE CONF
Yep.
Well, primary is an expression as well.
NOTE CONF
OK, so and the reason it says primary is because
it wants this to be the highest precedents, uh, bonding.
NOTE CONF
So we'll assume that's what it says now.
There was a section where you were saying, Look, this
NOTE CONF
primary is gonna evaluate, add to any old expression.
So a function called node in my abstract syntax tree
NOTE CONF
has on the left of it an expression and then
it.
NOTE CONF
Actually I think it also keeps track of the left
parenthesis for some reason.
NOTE CONF
And then it's got a list of arguments over here,
which I do just as a has a list that's
NOTE CONF
maybe got many things inside it.
That's what my abstract syntax tree for a function call
NOTE CONF
looks like, right?
But we know not just any old expression can go
NOTE CONF
in here.
We know that this has to be somehow one of
NOTE CONF
these locks callable.
This is what we did last week, right?
NOTE CONF
I'm not mixing up my weeks.
Cool.
NOTE CONF
So the thing to notice here is that we had
a generous Parsa or a, um uh well, let's say
NOTE CONF
generous.
We had a generous pasa, plus a run time check.
NOTE CONF
So we were getting a runtime error if we tried
to use syntax like, um, the parler would accept something
NOTE CONF
like this, but the runtime would then complain that a
string is not callable.
NOTE CONF
Cool.
Alright, what did we do for, say things like division?
NOTE CONF
So we know that one divided by three makes sense,
but I divided by there, does not make sense.
NOTE CONF
So what did our language do there?
Yeah.
NOTE CONF
What's that?
It's a string checking if it's a string.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, but when did it do that?
Because over here, I not no Notice that there's a
NOTE CONF
generous passer and a runtime check.
Did we have a Parsa that prevented this?
NOTE CONF
No.
The Parsa accepted it.
NOTE CONF
And a runtime check.
So as you can.
NOTE CONF
I'm suggesting this is where you might end up in
yours.
NOTE CONF
So now we're in a situation where we've got, um
It just says loop right?
NOTE CONF
Is that the keyword I used?
Yeah, loop V I equals and we're wondering this might
NOTE CONF
be something silly.
Like five plus three.
NOTE CONF
So should we check for this?
Well, the answer, of course.
NOTE CONF
Is it somewhere?
Somehow?
NOTE CONF
Yes.
You can't run it, But where do you check for
NOTE CONF
it?
Um and so I'm gonna suggest that the sensible thing
NOTE CONF
is to correctly pause it and the run time.
Well, there's a runtime error.
NOTE CONF
So interpreter error and I suggest in particular you reuse
the you.
NOTE CONF
You You look at the code for the call for
your inspiration to tell you exactly how to do that.
NOTE CONF
Yes.
So as you have the partial accepted, uh, in inside
NOTE CONF
that making something and then the interpreter will say OK,
Yeah.
NOTE CONF
Well, in this case, it'll say, you know, this, uh,
it might say something like, uh in Well, number just
NOTE CONF
uses number right number found, String expected.
Well, some kind of error response.
NOTE CONF
Let's go and have a look specifically at what the
call thing does.
NOTE CONF
So I'll stop sharing here.
OK, so call was week 10.
NOTE CONF
Yeah.
I'm like, Wait, wait.
NOTE CONF
Um, What are we gonna make over there?
No.
NOTE CONF
OK, so we were doing in the interpreter.
What were we doing?
NOTE CONF
So we were getting to a call node.
So we need the visit Call of something.
NOTE CONF
Yep.
Uh, visit call Expression is where the action is.
NOTE CONF
And our interpreter was saying, if the callee is not
an instance of the right kind, throw a run time,
NOTE CONF
I reckon.
Only call functions and glasses.
NOTE CONF
So your only decision is what should you put in
this string?
NOTE CONF
Really?
And as I said on the forums, I'm not checking
NOTE CONF
exactly the string output for these new errors that you're
making up.
NOTE CONF
I'm just checking that you are throwing a runtime error.
Um, as required, which just means you're output 65 or
NOTE CONF
whatever the exit code was.
That's built into locks.
NOTE CONF
Uh, cos.
Locks.
NOTE CONF
I think output zero for a programme that ran correctly
and something else for an a.
NOTE CONF
An error, an error of any variety.
Does that answer that?
NOTE CONF
Yep.
And now the other question was related.
NOTE CONF
There was war.
And while in the is there a way to store
NOTE CONF
and access a variable while we're in the string loop?
So let's go through a couple of things That could
NOTE CONF
mean and then we'll see.
Why is a variable.
NOTE CONF
It was like the It was like the first part
of it, like the first part of OK, But it
NOTE CONF
also requires access to that.
Yes.
NOTE CONF
So the point being is that I've just declared a
variable here, OK?
NOTE CONF
And this variable should not exist up here and should
not exist here.
NOTE CONF
But it should exist here.
Yeah, and so you're asking Is there a way to
NOTE CONF
do that?
Yeah, the answer is, of course, there's a way to
NOTE CONF
do that and it's kind of your job to find
out, but I can't give you a clue, which is
NOTE CONF
the same thing that's been used everywhere else is that
it's careful use of environments.
NOTE CONF
The environment is where we're controlling what variables exist and
don't exist.
NOTE CONF
So look to yourself, look for inspiration as to what
the code might do on something like this.
NOTE CONF
If you just created yourself a block and put a
declaration at the top, what would the effect of that
NOTE CONF
be?
And whatever the effect of that is is probably what
NOTE CONF
you want to emulate in yours.
So you have to go and trace this one and
NOTE CONF
work out what the effect of that code is and
you go well, OK, that's the kind of thing I'm
NOTE CONF
trying to do up here.
I'm trying to do something very similar.
NOTE CONF
It's like there's a block that's starting.
And then the kind of first thing I do in
NOTE CONF
that block is make myself a variable.
Um, and then start my loop.
NOTE CONF
Does that answer the question?
Oh, really?
NOTE CONF
You try to rephrase it or point me in the
right direction?
NOTE CONF
No, that's OK.
I'm happy to come back to that.
NOTE CONF
If you've got more on that question later, um, anybody
else got things they want to poke and prod at
NOTE CONF
before I just start ranting?
No.
NOTE CONF
Alright.
So what are we doing this week?
NOTE CONF
Are we doing something?
What are we doing?
NOTE CONF
Do you know who's looked?
Function declarations?
NOTE CONF
That's right.
Um so we made it to the point where we
NOTE CONF
were able to call functions and then there were no
functions in existence.
NOTE CONF
So we created this situation where functions would be added
to the environment for us.
NOTE CONF
And now we're going to start declaring our own functions
again.
NOTE CONF
I'm gonna harp on about the the need to come
up with a notation or a way of understanding what's
NOTE CONF
going on that works for you again.
I will do my own On my piece of paper.
NOTE CONF
I spent basically all of last Friday afternoon experimenting with
ways to kind of animate what's going on so I
NOTE CONF
could give you an answer.
And in the end, I came to the conclusion that
NOTE CONF
my animation is so tightly tied to my own understanding
that, yes, it's great to help me understand, but probably
NOTE CONF
will only help.
A small percentage of you understand.
NOTE CONF
What you've really gotta do is your own animation in
your like by doing your own drawings and rubbing bits
NOTE CONF
out and putting new bits in to find one that
works for you.
NOTE CONF
And so again, I'll demonstrate that back on the same
concepts, even though we're we've got this function declaration thing,
NOTE CONF
we we're learning this week.
Um, it's mostly still about function, calls and stuff, but
NOTE CONF
because next week it's gonna really matter to understand the
thing that we talk about next week, you gotta really
NOTE CONF
understand the mechanics of what's going on in the interpreter
when a function call occurs, uh, a function call of
NOTE CONF
a function that you've defined occurs so we will bang
on about that a bit this week.
NOTE CONF
OK, Craig Foster, whatever that is.
OK, so let's do a tour of what's going on
NOTE CONF
here.
Um, he makes a side note here about a named
NOTE CONF
function declaration isn't really a single primitive operation.
It's syntactic sugar for two distinct steps, creating a new
NOTE CONF
function thing and binding that function thing to a variable.
Um, that's a really important point that I'm hoping we're
NOTE CONF
starting to get.
But by seeing that thing on the right hand side,
NOTE CONF
you should start to realise that the definition of a
function what what effect does it have or where does
NOTE CONF
it have its effect?
It's in the environment because, just like a declaration of
NOTE CONF
a variable creates a new entry in the environment.
Declaration of a function also creates a new entry in
NOTE CONF
the environment.
So I'm gonna draw the environment to remind you what
NOTE CONF
we're talking about here.
So maybe we'll write a little bit of code and
NOTE CONF
just trace through what the environment does while the code
executes.
NOTE CONF
Shall we do that?
Yes, let's do that.
NOTE CONF
So if I've got V, I equals three and then
I've got I equals five and then I've got V.
NOTE CONF
Y equals I.
And then I've got print.
NOTE CONF
Why, Oh, semicolons.
Which I keep forgetting That's invalid locks code.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, and the way the interpreter goes through this is
it creates a environment for the start of the programme.
NOTE CONF
And let's say there's nothing in there.
We're not doing functions just yet.
NOTE CONF
It's just empty, but really, there's some global functions in
there, but we'll step into that in a sec.
NOTE CONF
Then it runs this first line and the environment gets
updated.
NOTE CONF
The the single environment that's already there, I'm just gonna
make it a bigger square.
NOTE CONF
So I've got all the space I need.
So as I execute this line, the environment looks like
NOTE CONF
that.
So at the start of executing this line before, before
NOTE CONF
executing this line, the environment looks like that After executing
this line, my interpreter goes to the only environment that
NOTE CONF
it knows about and sets a new thing called I
and makes it point to the value.
NOTE CONF
Three.
So before this line, I've got this environment.
NOTE CONF
After this line, it goes into the environment and updates
the three into a five before this line.
NOTE CONF
That's my environment.
After this line, it creates a new entry in the
NOTE CONF
environment, and this is key.
The entry in the environment is, you know, the identifier
NOTE CONF
pointing to a value that's all that the IT stores.
We should see this in the type of the environment,
NOTE CONF
which should be a map from.
I'm not quite sure what they got in there maybe
NOTE CONF
token or something, um, to an object.
And remember, for us we were keeping track.
NOTE CONF
That object meant the run time, value and expression meant
the compile time value.
NOTE CONF
So we're obviously only putting runtime values in there.
So before the line print Y, that's the state after
NOTE CONF
the line print Y.
The state is exactly the same.
NOTE CONF
So we just That's why I need an animation to
kind of show this because there's only one environment, but
NOTE CONF
it updates.
That's key.
NOTE CONF
Now what really happens?
Going to the very start is that this environment actually
NOTE CONF
had something in there.
It had this clock global function already in there, and
NOTE CONF
then the whole definition of clock, a whole like locks
callable thing was here, and because a locks callable is
NOTE CONF
a perfectly valid object that worked OK?
And then after the first line, we added IRO three.
NOTE CONF
Then, after the next line, we updated that to five.
And then we added Why it goes to five and
NOTE CONF
that was the environment at the end.
So maybe you can expect What am I expecting to
NOTE CONF
do now?
If I see is it fun or death?
NOTE CONF
It's fun.
What am I expecting something like this to do?
NOTE CONF
I'm expecting it to update the environment with the new
locks callable.
NOTE CONF
So my environment goes from being just a set of,
uh, identifier to value bindings to now being a set
NOTE CONF
of identifier to value bindings, plot and a set of
identifier to either a value or a function definition.
NOTE CONF
But as I think, I'm pretty sure I mentioned LA
last week that that forces us to say that function
NOTE CONF
like undefined functions.
Sorry.
NOTE CONF
Unapplied functions are a kind of value in this language.
Cool.
NOTE CONF
That's all we gotta do on our function definition, then
with one other caveat.
NOTE CONF
OK, so we put function definition in with so function
declarations in with the other declarations.
NOTE CONF
So a perfect spot for it, um, there's a grammar
for it it has an identifier in the front, then
NOTE CONF
a set of parameters, then a block.
Now this is useful.
NOTE CONF
Actually, we don't have to parse out the little the,
um inverted.
NOTE CONF
Uh, sorry.
The braces.
NOTE CONF
We don't have to parse out these braces because locks
already has a parser for something that starts with braces.
NOTE CONF
It's the block, um, grammar expression.
So that's another reason that it's useful to have blocks
NOTE CONF
as a first class thing in your pasa cos they
appear in so many places and they all get pas
NOTE CONF
the same way.
Now do notice, though, that when we did ifs and
NOTE CONF
loops, we didn't actually use the block grammar in that
slot.
NOTE CONF
What did we use in that slot?
You can go back and look, you got computers when?
NOTE CONF
So the grammar that we've just seen for this one
is the fun string and identifier, a set of parameters
NOTE CONF
and a block.
And I said, It's very cool, cos Block already does
NOTE CONF
the the the braces for us.
But on 10 on our other expression that also did
NOTE CONF
braces say, for example, ifs or loops.
We didn't use block.
NOTE CONF
What did we use?
Just statement.
NOTE CONF
Um Can anyone guess why?
Cos it's gonna be one line by putting statement.
NOTE CONF
We allow just one line or multiple lines by going
on.
NOTE CONF
And not just any old statement can go in here.
Only a block statement.
NOTE CONF
We're forcing there to be the braces on a function,
which is exactly what you and I expect.
NOTE CONF
You and I don't expect to be able to write
single line functions.
NOTE CONF
OK, parameters work like we expect parameters to work.
We need another abstract syntax tree node for this.
NOTE CONF
Now, the other one.
We had a call node for function call.
NOTE CONF
We've got a function node for a function declaration.
It uses a token for the name A list of
NOTE CONF
tokens for the parameters.
No, that's fine.
NOTE CONF
Yes, I was thinking about a function call.
I'm like, Hey, that's not gonna work.
NOTE CONF
You need expressions in there.
You only need expressions in there on the function.
NOTE CONF
Call on the function declaration side.
Yeah, they're definitely just identifier because they're just the variables
NOTE CONF
that you're gonna use that then that's the only thing
you can put in there.
NOTE CONF
And then a list of statements which is the body
and the Parsa for it.
NOTE CONF
runs just like the PSAs do.
There's nothing particularly interesting here.
NOTE CONF
So I think I can just kind of skip over
that.
NOTE CONF
Um oh, it's, you know, this is all the same.
He just checks for parameters.
NOTE CONF
Oh, but he does do this.
Check on the number of parameters that are allowed.
NOTE CONF
OK, so, yeah, sit down for, uh, V.
For what reason?
NOTE CONF
Uh, for the same back.
So we had the same check when we did function
NOTE CONF
calls.
So he's just enforcing the same check there and back
NOTE CONF
on function calls.
He did it?
NOTE CONF
Um uh, kind of, Just because, um ultimately, in a
programming language, you have to say, What's the maximum number
NOTE CONF
of parameters?
Because it can't be infinite.
NOTE CONF
So if you've gotta say the number, you might as
well pick a number.
NOTE CONF
And he chose 255.
Um, but that's just matching up with the one from
NOTE CONF
before, But in a language, if you would in an
interpreter like this, you can actually accept hundreds of thousands
NOTE CONF
and still make it work.
Um, but you might be swapping out memory just to
NOTE CONF
store your parameters.
And now your code is very slow.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, OK.
And also note that he's doing this validation at pas
NOTE CONF
time rather than at run time.
Keep This is a design principle.
NOTE CONF
We should see if we can check it at pastime.
We should check it at pastime.
NOTE CONF
The sooner we do our checks, the the easier it
is in our programmer.
NOTE CONF
The check we were talking about before Where is the
string loop Working on a string or not?
NOTE CONF
We can't possibly do that at Pastime because we've got
to evaluate that thing to find out if it's a
NOTE CONF
string.
But no evaluation is required to check how many parameters
NOTE CONF
have been passed in here.
So we can do that at Pa.
NOTE CONF
And then we just keep back the new node.
So at this point, we haven't done at this point.
NOTE CONF
There's no locks callable involved or anything like that because
we're just instructing the syntax tree I wanna keep straight
NOTE CONF
in your mind that it the syntax tree four function
calls had an expression slash locks callable on the left.
NOTE CONF
Um, so we just it it was typed as an
expression, but we knew deep inside it was a locks
NOTE CONF
callable, whereas our syntax tree for our function definition is
going to be, in this case, function with the token
NOTE CONF
food, a list of parameters which is empty, and then
a block.
NOTE CONF
Well, I've written block there, but he's actually in the
language, Um, stripped out the little block bit and just
NOTE CONF
gone straight to our list of statements.
And then on this one, there's a single statement which
NOTE CONF
is a print, which hasn't it, Uh, why?
OK, so there's no lock callable involved at this point.
NOTE CONF
Um, why was that?
Well, the function the function call relies on there being
NOTE CONF
some locks.
Callable somewhere, the function definition is the thing that's gonna
NOTE CONF
create the locks callable, but not until runtime doesn't create
a pastime at Pastime.
NOTE CONF
We've got this kind of template from which we know
we can build a lock callable, but we haven't built
NOTE CONF
it yet.
The main reason why Well, one reason why is that
NOTE CONF
If we've got if we call Fu twice, we don't
want to be reusing the same callable over and over,
NOTE CONF
or we're gonna have trouble with recursion.
So it's a one time thing where we got to
NOTE CONF
fire up a new call a ball.
OK, OK, so function objects here um he makes a
NOTE CONF
whole new file for lock functions, which are things that
are gonna be created at run time.
NOTE CONF
But they are just those locks.
It's just a in an implementation of the locks Callable.
NOTE CONF
You remember before we were doing anonymous inner classes to
implement our locks callable.
NOTE CONF
But here, anything that comes from a function definition, well,
it it's gonna work the same way.
NOTE CONF
So let's make a a real class for it.
OK, so it's got access to its original a ST
NOTE CONF
node.
That's what this is.
NOTE CONF
Um, just says, Look, I, I might need to look
that up.
NOTE CONF
In fact, you definitely will need to look that up.
So this is my one time interpretation of the of
NOTE CONF
the function.
Link me back to the original a ST node and
NOTE CONF
build a special locks callable and then override the methods,
which is what a locks callable means.
NOTE CONF
And we'll go through what this does.
Um, and then we execute the block directly out of
NOTE CONF
the A ST node.
So what I'm gonna do is I'm just gonna I'm
NOTE CONF
gonna draw a diagram to show you how this works.
He's got his own diagrams here.
NOTE CONF
but I'm gonna draw my own.
We're just gonna go through a diagram of this process.
NOTE CONF
Let's do it for, um this function decoration that I've
got here.
NOTE CONF
So I'll bring back up other questions at this point.
By the way, when I'm ranting, you all drift away.
NOTE CONF
Come back to me.
Cool.
NOTE CONF
Alright, um, we're gonna do the diagram of exactly what's
going on here.
NOTE CONF
So you have your crafting interpreters book open in front
of you on that section of the code so that
NOTE CONF
you can look back and forth with what I'm doing
and tell me when I make a mistake.
NOTE CONF
So we've worked out that when we pause fun, I'll
just use ident friends, arguments, friends block because that we
NOTE CONF
get a function a ST node with the ident over
here, the arguments in here and the block and hit.
NOTE CONF
So let's write a function.
And let's do that that my function is function food
NOTE CONF
with no parameters print.
Why just all by itself?
NOTE CONF
OK, so that's going to pass into which I did
before.
NOTE CONF
But that's just I think I have to put variable
here, don't I to to really be the same as
NOTE CONF
the abstract Syntex tree.
Um And then we introduced this other thing somewhere that
NOTE CONF
got created along the way.
This this function which implements locks callable.
NOTE CONF
So I just wanna show you how that relates.
It doesn't exist till run time.
NOTE CONF
But what was it called in the It's just called
a function It's not.
NOTE CONF
It's called a function something else, right?
No, just function.
NOTE CONF
This one over here is STMT dot function.
So this one, I think, is just function by itself.
NOTE CONF
Um, so that's an object.
Well, it is me joining as a class and it's
NOTE CONF
got a declaration which points back to that thing.
And it's got a arity method which inspects this thing
NOTE CONF
to find out.
And it's got a call method which inspects this thing
NOTE CONF
to do its job so we can think of us
as having a duality here.
NOTE CONF
We've got the we've now got the the text version
of a function.
NOTE CONF
We've got the a ST version of a function and
we've got the run time version of a function.
NOTE CONF
But it I think it's key to note that the
runtime version of a function, because we know that a
NOTE CONF
STS exist at run time that they're part of the
runtime game.
NOTE CONF
But it's OK for this a ST this runtime function
to keep referring back to the original a ST when
NOTE CONF
it wants to find out some information.
Like how many parameters do I have?
NOTE CONF
Uh, when I run What ex What what?
Um, statements.
NOTE CONF
Am I running?
OK, so that that's this part of the of the
NOTE CONF
execution, But we can see that the the Calwell actually
sets up something else at one time.
NOTE CONF
It sets up the environment, uh, ready to go.
So let's try and draw a diagram to explain what
NOTE CONF
it's doing there.
Um, so let me just so just a reminder that
NOTE CONF
when we execute any statement or block of statements in
this language, we tell it what environment to use during
NOTE CONF
that execution.
We don't just use the global environment all the time,
NOTE CONF
and we learnt why that was because when we introduced
a new block, we couldn't just add new things to
NOTE CONF
the environment.
We had to create a child environment and the top
NOTE CONF
environment.
We had to run with the child environment and defer
NOTE CONF
back when we needed to.
That was important because we had to once the block
NOTE CONF
was finished.
Throw away the child environment and go back to the
NOTE CONF
original one.
That's the whole reason we were keeping this little cactus
NOTE CONF
of environments because it was a bit like a stack.
We had to throw away the old environments once we
NOTE CONF
got out of the block.
OK, so call doesn't just execute the body directly.
NOTE CONF
So let me back that up, can I?
But by doing that, I'm getting rid of these dots.
NOTE CONF
Here we go.
That's as far as I can go.
NOTE CONF
What am I?
So Cole doesn't directly execute the the statements.
NOTE CONF
It does one thing 1st.
1st, it sets up the new environments.
NOTE CONF
What does that mean?
That means get the environment from before it's called, uh,
NOTE CONF
Alpha and then create appropriate.
And from that, creating that appropriate end means using Alpha
NOTE CONF
as the parent environment.
Having a sub environment under that and every parameter gets
NOTE CONF
its values in that sub environment, and so we'll call
that beta.
NOTE CONF
So this is beta.
So from here on in, once we're inside the function,
NOTE CONF
whatever the environment was prior to the function is the
super environment.
NOTE CONF
All of the parameters are added into the environment and
off we go, then we just execute ourselves as normal.
NOTE CONF
That sounds reasonable.
Yeah, but you better be pretty comfortable with this parent
NOTE CONF
environment, child environment relationship, um, to follow along.
So when we look at our code now, we can
NOTE CONF
maybe see that's what it's doing.
It's grabbing the environment from before that line.
NOTE CONF
It's got it down as interpreted at Global's in this
case.
NOTE CONF
But we're about to fix that.
Um and then it's creating a new environment from that.
NOTE CONF
No, it's adding into that environment.
Oh, that's broken.
NOTE CONF
Let's go find the real one.
Hang on.
NOTE CONF
Where did you do the real one?
I jumped ahead compared to how he does things.
NOTE CONF
Oh, OK, so he introduces the problem first.
Oh, what?
NOTE CONF
Alright.
Well, maybe I've jumped ahead to the next chapter.
NOTE CONF
Alright, So let's just look at what he actually does
then and be precise about what he actually does.
NOTE CONF
He's grabbing the global environment and he's adding new definitions
to it, So he's not doing what I drew.
NOTE CONF
Well, we're certainly gonna see a problem next week.
So what he's actually doing is this.
NOTE CONF
Take the original one and add the new things in
OK, all right, so I know a little bit better,
NOTE CONF
So I know that's not a good idea.
We'll get to that next week.
NOTE CONF
Um, and I've already given you a preview of why
that's not necessarily the best idea, but that's what we're
NOTE CONF
doing for now, because certainly we need these new parameters
to come into existence.
NOTE CONF
Um, and what's this question mark gonna be?
Well, by the time we're running the call function, we
NOTE CONF
know what those are gonna be.
Because the call function has all the actual arguments being
NOTE CONF
passed in So we can say the formal parameter P
gets mapped to the actual parameter.
NOTE CONF
Whatever it evaluated to the second formal parameter evaluates to
it, the second actual parameter evaluates to and our environment
NOTE CONF
is all ready to go for us to execute the
body of the function.
NOTE CONF
So he says, here, each function call gets its own
environment.
NOTE CONF
Otherwise, a recursion would break if there are multiple calls
to the same function at the same time, it needs
NOTE CONF
its own environment, even though they were all calls to
the same function.
NOTE CONF
That's why we create a new environment at each call.
Not at the function declaration at the beginning of the
NOTE CONF
call, it creates the new environment.
Then it walks the perimeter argument.
NOTE CONF
Oh, so it is sorry.
It is creating what I described.
NOTE CONF
You guys aren't paying attention.
I made a mistake.
NOTE CONF
When you do a new environment and you pass in
another environment, you're exactly setting up the diagram that I
NOTE CONF
had.
You're exactly setting it up with the parents set up.
NOTE CONF
Good, good, good, good.
All right.
NOTE CONF
So this this top line here environment equals new environment.
Interpreter got global's.
NOTE CONF
Hello is you know, this is the interpret a new
interpret the alpha.
NOTE CONF
Uh, you're telling it what the parent is rather than
adding into the existing one.
NOTE CONF
Alright.
Better.
NOTE CONF
I knew that couldn't work.
That would break much sooner than the problem he's actually
NOTE CONF
got for the next chapter.
OK, but you can see here that, uh, in his
NOTE CONF
he's using interpreter do global, which is the just the
global environment that's always available.
NOTE CONF
Um, that's that's not gonna work because we have you
can do function decorations inside other function declarations in a
NOTE CONF
language like you're used to where function decorations can only
sit at the very top of the language.
NOTE CONF
That would be just fine.
Cos the only environment that might be around a function
NOTE CONF
is the global environment and so using global's.
But it's not OK, once you get a little bit
NOTE CONF
further in should we try and trace this convoluted way
to count to three with our own diagram similar to
NOTE CONF
his?
Yeah, let's try that.
NOTE CONF
Just scanning ahead a little bit.
OK, so we already said this, but I'm just going
NOTE CONF
ahead to make sure I've said everything that's gonna need
to make sense for this.
NOTE CONF
OK, let's trace this little fella here, so function and
count N, I'll write it up first.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, Alright.
So this pers, this piece of code is gonna be
NOTE CONF
create is gonna create an abstract syntax tree.
Remember, abstract syntax trees, environments don't kick in until we
NOTE CONF
start running through an abstract syntax tree.
So what's it gonna create?
NOTE CONF
Well, there are two statements in this cos remember that,
uh, overall a programme is actually a list of statements.
NOTE CONF
So this is my notation that I'm using now for
lists of things, cos I need them in my a
NOTE CONF
ST.
So there are two possible statements here the first one.
NOTE CONF
It's obviously the function declaration and its first thing was
the count and it had a list of parameters and
NOTE CONF
there was one in there, which was N and its
body was a list of statements.
NOTE CONF
The number of statements in its body was two, and
the first statement was an if which had a condition,
NOTE CONF
which was a binary which was and greater than one,
and it had a body and its body was a
NOTE CONF
single statement, which was a call.
It was a call to count with the parameter list.
NOTE CONF
It had a single thing in it, which was a
binary which was an N and a minus and a
NOTE CONF
one R.
And then the second statement was a print of an
NOTE CONF
N.
Uh, let's call it a variable N OK, so that
NOTE CONF
dealt with the function.
And then the second statement of the programme was the
NOTE CONF
coal The count with the parameter list in row three.
There you go.
NOTE CONF
OK, so there's an a ST for my programme.
Happy now?
NOTE CONF
Just notice a few things I'm doing that I weren't
doing before just because it works out for me in
NOTE CONF
the area.
I'm at now, Sometimes I'm putting in the the literals
NOTE CONF
there.
And the variables there they are all variable.
NOTE CONF
Sometimes I'm not that, uh, OK, whatever this is for
my understanding.
NOTE CONF
More than anything else, I started using this notation to
tell me when things are are lists of things.
NOTE CONF
And then there's just a single thing in it.
I just do a line below.
NOTE CONF
Whereas before I was probably leaving out the list bit
again.
NOTE CONF
This is from my understanding.
So what's the interpreter gonna do as it traverses this
NOTE CONF
tree?
Now the interpreter has the environment.
NOTE CONF
It starts up before it even gets going.
Let's try and let's try and visualise this at the
NOTE CONF
point where it's doing this.
That's where things Oh, no.
NOTE CONF
OK, at the point where it's doing this, it builds
the global environment later on.
NOTE CONF
So I'm gonna draw that, Uh, maybe I'll draw that
all the way down here.
NOTE CONF
That's my environment.
Mm.
NOTE CONF
That's a start in multiple spots.
This can be my brother.
NOTE CONF
So that's my global environment.
And in this interpreter, the global environment includes clock, which
NOTE CONF
is a native function right or something.
So that's there already at this point, and that's really
NOTE CONF
all it does on that first step.
And then the next thing it does is it traverses
NOTE CONF
down to the function.
What does it do when it visits the function?
NOTE CONF
So that's our visit function?
No.
NOTE CONF
You guys have a look.
Open up your locks or the textbook.
NOTE CONF
What does it do when it visits the function?
OK, so I think it builds a new locks callable
NOTE CONF
that it puts in here.
So I think it puts into here.
NOTE CONF
Now.
I'm actually gonna label this native function alpha, because I
NOTE CONF
need to put it on my diagram, because that alpha
is actually this thing.
NOTE CONF
Um, I'll just use this bit here.
It's a locks callable, but it points in to that
NOTE CONF
parameter list, and it points to the body in case
it need because it needs them.
NOTE CONF
So that's what Alpha does.
Um, and actually, we just stop dead there, don't we?
NOTE CONF
We don't traverse down into this tree at all.
That's a cool thing to notice.
NOTE CONF
OK, so that was Step one.
Step two.
NOTE CONF
What do we do?
Step three.
NOTE CONF
You visit the call.
Hey, what does visiting Nicole do?
NOTE CONF
But it checks the well, actually.
So let me just double check.
NOTE CONF
There was something else going on in this alpha that
I didn't talk about.
NOTE CONF
Um, so let me go back.
The Alpha didn't just set up the list of parameters
NOTE CONF
and didn't just set up the list of statements.
It set up one other thing as well.
NOTE CONF
Which was this nice new environment we were gonna use?
Didnt Let's go look, because this is just visiting function.
NOTE CONF
So where's visit function gone?
I'm visiting Call.
NOTE CONF
Who's that?
So the visit function statement creates a new locks function
NOTE CONF
that's my alpha and then adds that into my environment.
So I've done all that.
NOTE CONF
But let's just double check what this loss function thing
does do.
NOTE CONF
Do do we can't.
Am I on the wrong freaking, uh, I've just gone
NOTE CONF
too far.
So this is our definition of locks function, which all
NOTE CONF
happens at when you create an object of lock function.
Right?
NOTE CONF
Uh, there's this.
It hasn't happened yet because the call hasn't happened, but
NOTE CONF
we're going to eventually build this.
So this isn't just me double checking.
NOTE CONF
Have I already built my environment?
No, I haven't.
NOTE CONF
Um that's gonna wait for the call, So let's go
back.
NOTE CONF
So I was right.
This was the exact situation.
NOTE CONF
But these little details matter when we're trying to understand
what the heck's going on.
NOTE CONF
So at this point, no, nothing's been built here yet.
And as I was tracing that, I'm like, Oh, if
NOTE CONF
I try and build the environment now, that's not gonna
work cos I don't know what the end points to,
NOTE CONF
um this this matters Alright, so that's where we're at
after visiting function now we visit Call might just put
NOTE CONF
lines through these, since they're finished.
So when we visit call What does a visit call
NOTE CONF
statement do?
Well, it looks at the environment and finds out that
NOTE CONF
there's Count gets back one of these Alphas and call
it.
NOTE CONF
So at this point, we pull Alpha.
No, we actually, before we do that, we actually evaluate
NOTE CONF
this body.
So let's do that.
NOTE CONF
If you go and look at the visit call, you'll
find out that before it does any of that, it
NOTE CONF
evaluates who it evaluates this.
So that's the next step for and then to do
NOTE CONF
that.
Sorry to evaluate that it evaluates this so that's five.
NOTE CONF
And to evaluate that stop doing that sorry to evaluate
that.
NOTE CONF
It evaluates this.
So that's six and then having done that, Yeah.
NOTE CONF
Um this gets replaced with the number three cool.
And so now we're back up.
NOTE CONF
This call was still kind of sitting there.
Uh, that was call number three.
NOTE CONF
Remember?
Um, now that we've finished with that, it's ready to
NOTE CONF
do the next part, which is to go up.
Go look in the environment for account, grab the alpha
NOTE CONF
and call it with the three.
Alright.
NOTE CONF
What does that do?
What does alpha dot call three do.
NOTE CONF
Ok, Well, this is our alpha.
So Well, we checked the core method, which I just
NOTE CONF
did before.
We'll find that the every time you call a call
NOTE CONF
method.
So let's put a little side thing off here because
NOTE CONF
we're calling call.
We build ourselves a new environment and we put into
NOTE CONF
that environment end points to three and that environment's parent
is this environment and then using that environment, we start
NOTE CONF
executing.
So we execute that one, which is the same as
NOTE CONF
executing this one, which is the same as ex.
I'll leave those ones in there cos they're still in
NOTE CONF
process, which is the same as executing this one, which
is OK.
NOTE CONF
Same as executing this one, which is three.
And then we work out that that one is false
NOTE CONF
and we don't do anything.
No, that one's true.
NOTE CONF
Come on, pay attention.
Ok, so that one's true.
NOTE CONF
So now the execution goes to here and these ones
are done.
NOTE CONF
And now the execution goes to head.
Alright, What does coal do exactly what it did before?
NOTE CONF
Coal now goes OK, so I execute the body.
OK, three minus one is two two.
NOTE CONF
So I do alpha dot call the two.
What does that do?
NOTE CONF
Well, that creates another function call with N Arrow two
and with my code at the moment, using that one
NOTE CONF
as the parent.
So then I execute.
NOTE CONF
So now that I've done that, I'm back executing the
body and a PD.
NOTE CONF
OK, so that gets rid of this and this and
this cos that got done, But I'm still trying to
NOTE CONF
execute alpha dot call.
What does that mean?
NOTE CONF
While I set the environment, But I also go back
up to the top here.
NOTE CONF
I bet I'm gonna need a new colour.
I go back up to the top here and execute
NOTE CONF
this again.
All right?
NOTE CONF
Yeah.
And the, um How of a form?
NOTE CONF
To which question do you use which which to use
which functions?
NOTE CONF
Because the environment has count.
So Alpha is actually a lock callable object with the
NOTE CONF
parameters pointing to the parameter list and the body pointing
to the statement list.
NOTE CONF
And so when you do dot call it, we've defined
it to actually execute those particular statements.
NOTE CONF
If there was a different function somewhere else, it would
look up that function, get a different locks callable, and
NOTE CONF
they would be pointing to a different set of statements.
Yeah, but now we're back at the top of that
NOTE CONF
same a AST again.
But the way it doesn't just do the same thing
NOTE CONF
again is because the current environment is different and the
current environment is now N pointing to two with that
NOTE CONF
as the parent.
And so you can see we'll just do the same
NOTE CONF
thing again and get down to the same spot again
and have to create another environment with N pointing to
NOTE CONF
one and then go back to the top of the
function again.
NOTE CONF
OK, The key is that we've got, uh, that there.
There's actually only one locks callable, but the the call
NOTE CONF
functions are firing up their own environment.
So I kind of think of it as there being
NOTE CONF
multiple locks.
Callable, there's only one, a ST node that's traversed over
NOTE CONF
and over again to work out what to do.
But every time we call, we're calling in the context
NOTE CONF
of a slightly different environment, and that's what makes everything
work the way it's supposed to within the call.
NOTE CONF
We could use any global because we would still be
able to get to them through that environment tree in
NOTE CONF
the call.
We use N and we get the correct one for
NOTE CONF
N in the call.
If we make any updates to N, they'll update this
NOTE CONF
one, Not that one up there.
Everything works the way we expect functions to work questions.
NOTE CONF
Right?
So that process I went through there where I was
NOTE CONF
tracing something and my trace, there was a mistake in
my trace that I had to go back to the
NOTE CONF
code to resolve is exactly what I want you guys
to be doing.
NOTE CONF
Um, that's how you I don't know if you remember
when you first learned Dykes and tree traversal algorithms.
NOTE CONF
But you would have had to do the same thing
then, to properly understand them.
NOTE CONF
Um, we're just We're in a more complicated tree traversal
here.
NOTE CONF
One way to think of comps 3000 is it takes
comp.
NOTE CONF
What is that?
That one's 2010 and just like says, Well, what if
NOTE CONF
we go berserk with our trees and do crazy things
to trees?
NOTE CONF
Uh uh, yeah, that's what we're doing.
We're building trees with passes.
NOTE CONF
We're traversing trees and carrying things around as we traverse
them, we're linking into parts of trees and reusing the
NOTE CONF
parts of those trees where we build other things beside
them.
NOTE CONF
We're basically just ramping up our tree ability, but at
the same time learning how an interpreter works and understanding
NOTE CONF
more about what our programmes do at run time.
OK, questions, thoughts, feelings.
NOTE CONF
I haven't been using flux, but when I use flux
in my other classes, I stop here and ask you
NOTE CONF
for your feelings.
You put a smiley face or a grumpy face just
NOTE CONF
to keep you engaged.
But I thought you 30 years, you'll be fine.
NOTE CONF
OK, But seriously, don't tune out because we're about to
go double down on this.
NOTE CONF
That's why I'm stopping to ask.
In fact, I may go get some water or just
NOTE CONF
have a drink.
What, you think there's gotta be some confusion?
NOTE CONF
Look at that mess.
Trace that again in your head and tell me where
NOTE CONF
you get confused.
So you had one good question.
NOTE CONF
That's the kind of question I'd speak more of.
Mhm.
NOTE CONF
I want this is happening and that is the way
that we this is all runtime.
NOTE CONF
So II I use the colours pastime blue run down
orange in an interpreter.
NOTE CONF
Those things are a little bit fuzzy, right?
Cos you just run the interpreter pas happens.
NOTE CONF
Interpreting happens and it spits out and it's done.
The reason we've kept track of what's past time and
NOTE CONF
run time is that in a compiled language, all the
blue things happen before you run it by the compiler,
NOTE CONF
and all the red things happen when you run it
by the run time.
NOTE CONF
But an interpreter.
You can't tell that from outside, but they are still
NOTE CONF
separate phases inside the nothing else.
No, let's roll.
NOTE CONF
We're about to hit closures the coolest Well, closures are
cool and simple, and hopefully they'll be presented to you
NOTE CONF
as cool and simple.
Who's heard the word closure before?
NOTE CONF
OK, what does it mean?
A lot of things.
NOTE CONF
What do you think of a, um I think of
the idea.
NOTE CONF
Yep.
So function scoping And what have you?
NOTE CONF
What do you think it means?
Isabel, You just heard the word, OK?
NOTE CONF
Anybody else heard the word?
No.
NOTE CONF
So I want you just to not worry too much
about the word.
NOTE CONF
And just look at the mechanic of what we're about
to do.
NOTE CONF
So here you can see that.
Just function calling.
NOTE CONF
I mean, you you you've called a million functions.
You know what's going on.
NOTE CONF
But you you had a AAA kind of instinctive or
an in Yeah, an instinctive version of what was going
NOTE CONF
on here in your head.
And we just made it all super explicit.
NOTE CONF
Um, so the machinery is there, So let's first start
with the implicit well, the instinctive understanding of so they
NOTE CONF
get a fancy name because they weren't in a lot
of early languages.
NOTE CONF
And so when that language had it, someone said, Oh,
it's got this feature and they made a nice word
NOTE CONF
for it.
OK, so we did all that.
NOTE CONF
Oh, we haven't done return statements yet.
Um, I'm gonna skip them and come back to them.
NOTE CONF
OK?
So key here is that lock function implementation of core
NOTE CONF
creates a new environment where it binds the function's parameters
good.
NOTE CONF
And we glossed over one point, What's the parent of
the environment?
NOTE CONF
Well, we just set it to global every time.
But locks allows you to write functions inside other functions.
NOTE CONF
So this is a valid piece of locks code.
So if you call the make counter function, you're you're
NOTE CONF
rebooting the F the counter and setting that variable I
to zero.
NOTE CONF
And then after that, um, you define a new function
called Count.
NOTE CONF
I've given you practise on this in the workshops.
I'm sure of it.
NOTE CONF
You do?
In fact, I made you go crazy with the ski
NOTE CONF
stuff.
Have you done the ski example yet, or is that
NOTE CONF
this week?
Yeah, Who get ready?
NOTE CONF
Or maybe I put that in a practise question.
You did?
NOTE CONF
Oh, you did the plus and increment.
Right?
NOTE CONF
Plus and increment.
OK, Yeah.
NOTE CONF
I decided ski was too hard, so I gave you
plus and increment first skis coming later, or maybe in
NOTE CONF
the distinction exams.
But anyway, you did that plus and increment example where
NOTE CONF
a function wasn't returning a value to you, it was
returning a whole new function definition.
NOTE CONF
Maybe you're a bit more comfortable with that now, cos
we've just seen that our environment holds values and function
NOTE CONF
definitions.
So we should be perfectly happy just treating them like
NOTE CONF
we treat any other value, right?
Yeah.
NOTE CONF
So this is another example.
When you make a counter, the return value is not
NOTE CONF
zero to say.
I've just restarted my counter.
NOTE CONF
The return value is the function you can call to
increment this counter.
NOTE CONF
And if I called make counter again, I'd get back
a totally separate count function that would increment a totally
NOTE CONF
separate counter.
What does this feel like?
NOTE CONF
What other programming, like, if you had to write something
like this where it said, make a counter and make
NOTE CONF
sure that it's got a special count function that only
incremented that counter.
NOTE CONF
How would you do it?
Objects?
NOTE CONF
Yes.
Four kind of.
NOTE CONF
You know, they're rich man's objects.
So, uh, by putting by having nested functions, we're able
NOTE CONF
to achieve the kinds of things you might think you
can only achieve with objects and methods.
NOTE CONF
But mechanically, all we're doing is just saying, Look, I'm
gonna set up a new variable and I'm gonna give
NOTE CONF
you back a function definition, but it's And here's the
function definition.
NOTE CONF
So obviously we're expecting that this will cause counter to
print one and two because it's got a print statement
NOTE CONF
and there are different counts.
But the only way that works is if the count
NOTE CONF
function has access to that I variable, which it wouldn't
in our current setup.
NOTE CONF
Because our current setup, whenever we made a new function,
we set up a environment for its parameters and its
NOTE CONF
parent environment was the global one.
And I doesn't exist in the global, so that's not
NOTE CONF
right.
Closures say OK, I'm gonna have to move away from
NOTE CONF
just using the global environment as the parent of a
function.
NOTE CONF
What environment should I use?
It shouldn't be too hard, I said, Just use the
NOTE CONF
environment I'm currently in.
Wherever I am, when you define me, that's my environment.
NOTE CONF
So the phone make counter will have created a separate
environment that has the global as its parent.
NOTE CONF
That's the environment we're at at the time when we
create the count.
NOTE CONF
So its parents should be the parent that we just
created.
NOTE CONF
Can someone see a problem?
No, there's probably not a problem.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, the reason closures, I guess.
Get an interesting name is that we already we already
NOTE CONF
set up our environments to be created when the function
was called.
NOTE CONF
But if we didn't have closures, we could cheat and
not do that.
NOTE CONF
We could create the environments, uh, earlier than that.
So it forces you to wait until function call because
NOTE CONF
at function, what at function?
Definition this.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, This is the bit that messes people head, but
it's not hard at function definition.
NOTE CONF
You know that it's the environment from make counter that
you want, but that environment doesn't exist yet.
NOTE CONF
You know that environment, it will exist and will have
a parent.
NOTE CONF
That's the global one.
But it doesn't exist yet because it doesn't exist until
NOTE CONF
it's cold.
OK, so you're all ready to go.
NOTE CONF
You're like the environment for count is gonna be whatever
the environment is for make counter and its environment is
NOTE CONF
gonna be the and its parent environment is gonna be
the the Global one and I'm ready to go.
NOTE CONF
But it's not all set up yet.
It's just, like, ready to be set up and then
NOTE CONF
I call mate counter and half of that's been filled
in.
NOTE CONF
I'm like, OK, now mate Count has got itself an
environment because when you call it, that's when the environment
NOTE CONF
gets built.
Now I can connect up the environment for count so
NOTE CONF
that when I call it, it's good to go as
well.
NOTE CONF
I make a brand new environment for it.
I already know exactly what its parent environment is gonna
NOTE CONF
be and off we go.
OK, so this is just him showing that it won't
NOTE CONF
work with the global one.
But we'll work with the Mount Counter Body one exactly
NOTE CONF
as we said.
So the only thing that has to change here is
NOTE CONF
that when we define the lock function, so remember this
is the, um, constructive for it.
NOTE CONF
So this this happens at pas time, we construct this
function.
NOTE CONF
Um, we need to remember what was the environment we
were defined in.
NOTE CONF
Just grab hold of it.
We grab hold of the environment we were defined in
NOTE CONF
and just hold on to it.
ready to go.
NOTE CONF
We're not using it yet, but we're ready to go.
And then, uh, so he makes a small ch change
NOTE CONF
here to pass in, uh, the environment that it's going
to be built from and then down here when we
NOTE CONF
actually get to the call.
This isn't the global environment anymore.
NOTE CONF
It's that one we grabbed when we were built, ready
to roll.
NOTE CONF
It will have been filled in by now, and we
can definitely use it.
NOTE CONF
OK, so here's an Here's an example of the way
that the environments would nest in that cou I'm gonna
NOTE CONF
jump back over to mine and show you what that
would have done to our example before.
NOTE CONF
OK, the only thing it actually does to this example
there is nothing.
NOTE CONF
OK, I was tempted to make the arrow go like
this, but that's not what's going to happen.
NOTE CONF
Let's let's Well, let's just double check.
So the code we just wrote on this complicated diagram
NOTE CONF
says that Alpha here has not just I got a
point over here.
NOTE CONF
I keep pointing on my screen.
It's no good to you.
NOTE CONF
Alpha over there has not just the list of parameters
not just the body, which I was pointing to, but
NOTE CONF
also the environment that was around when I hit the
definition.
NOTE CONF
Well, which environment was around when he hit the definition,
the global one?
NOTE CONF
So it remembers deep inside it somewhere as it's created.
So I remember these were the three things I did
NOTE CONF
when I created it right, the paras, the definition of
the body or whatever it was.
NOTE CONF
And now that's the closure.
So it just as it's built, it says, Oh, that's
NOTE CONF
the one I was constructed inside of.
So whenever I get to the coal, use that one
NOTE CONF
as my parent, when I've gotten to this coal, use
that one as my parent, Fine.
NOTE CONF
Done exactly the same thing.
And that's why he was using that example there because
NOTE CONF
it worked just fine.
But for the make counter one, it wouldn't work because
NOTE CONF
for the M count, So we have a quick look
at the main counter one.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, let's let's write up the A ST and quickly
track would trace it to the same extent here.
NOTE CONF
Um, but we'll trace it to try and see what's
going on, OK, so make counter words tell me if
NOTE CONF
I'm wrong.
It was fun.
NOTE CONF
So that was that programme.
So that created an A ST.
NOTE CONF
So the a ST it created was Well, it's well,
this one.
NOTE CONF
This one actually had some statements below it.
It had the make counter counter count, right?
NOTE CONF
Oops.
Sorry.
NOTE CONF
There was a that was different.
That was, uh, count equals Get up the other account.
NOTE CONF
OK, so this programme is three statements.
The first one is the most interesting one.
NOTE CONF
There's two others over here.
Sorry.
NOTE CONF
Four statements.
There's three others over here which we'll not worry about
NOTE CONF
for now, cos that's the the function called to make
count And that's the function called to count.
NOTE CONF
And that's the function called to count.
They're over there.
NOTE CONF
But over here, the first statement is the function definition,
which is my countdown, and it has no parameters and
NOTE CONF
its body is a list of statements and the first
statement is a V decal.
NOTE CONF
And the second statement is a function which is the
definition of count.
NOTE CONF
And the third statement is the return.
And so if I fill in the V Adele, it's
NOTE CONF
a I set to an expression which is a literal,
which is zero.
NOTE CONF
Then the function definition is count with an empty parameter
list and a body of two statements.
NOTE CONF
The first statement is the assignment operator.
Now is this How do I do?
NOTE CONF
I have an a ST?
No for assignment operators?
NOTE CONF
Or do I just use?
Can someone look it up and tell me what the
NOTE CONF
A ST node for an assignment operator is?
I've forgotten.
NOTE CONF
So theres two statements.
One's the assignment and one's the print.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, but what's the node called?
Is it called assignment or a sign or cool?
NOTE CONF
That makes sense.
So I got in the sign, which assigns I to
NOTE CONF
a value, which is a binary and the binary is
I plus a literal what?
NOTE CONF
OK, so I think that's yep, and that return there
returns the variable count and then we've got over here.
NOTE CONF
Our function calls, which is a call to Well, I'll
leave those out for now because I well, let's fill
NOTE CONF
it in.
Let's get it, um, make counter with an empty parameter
NOTE CONF
list.
That's a call to count with empty parameter lists, and
NOTE CONF
that's called to count.
And then two parameters.
NOTE CONF
Alright, there's my track index tree.
I've drawn some of it sideways this time.
NOTE CONF
So let's We're gonna go through what the interpreter does.
As I say, Not in quite so much detail.
NOTE CONF
Interpreter visits here.
Let's do that.
NOTE CONF
Let's call it number one.
I won't put circles this time.
NOTE CONF
I'll just put numbers.
Um, number one.
NOTE CONF
When we visit there, we create our global environment, which
has clock in it.
NOTE CONF
Yep.
Easy number two revisit that node function that node goes
NOTE CONF
to.
So when we visit that node, what do we do?
NOTE CONF
We we add a new locks callable to the environment,
which I call Alpha, and we construct this alpha.
NOTE CONF
And in constructing this alpha, we say, those are your
perms.
NOTE CONF
That's the body.
And that's the closure.
NOTE CONF
I'd say we might, because the Alpha points Well, I
drew the line around the Alpha because the Alpha was
NOTE CONF
including all these.
But now I'd have to draw the Alpha all the
NOTE CONF
way around that whole thing as well.
So I might not do that.
NOTE CONF
I'll just stop there.
So this is our alpha.
NOTE CONF
It's our little locks callable, but it talks to other
important parts of the tree.
NOTE CONF
That's it done.
We don't visit any more of that we go visit
NOTE CONF
the function core, which is number three.
When we visit a function call, we look up the
NOTE CONF
current environment, which is this one.
Uh so this one and we find out what make
NOTE CONF
counter is which is Alpha and we do alpha dot
call.
NOTE CONF
So at this point, we do an alpha.co Alpha.co says
I'm making a brand new environment.
NOTE CONF
In this case.
Nothing new goes in it because there's no parameters and
NOTE CONF
its parent is my closure.
So it's that guy and I started executing the body
NOTE CONF
of Alpha.
So I move over here.
NOTE CONF
So next step number four is this one.
But importantly, four is happening with this environment.
NOTE CONF
Not this environment.
So five goes over there.
NOTE CONF
So in this environment, that means this because we got
then six goes over here.
NOTE CONF
Alright?
Six is visiting another function.
NOTE CONF
So what does a function definition do?
It goes to the current environment and makes our locks
NOTE CONF
gullible.
Alright.
NOTE CONF
What's my beta?
My beta as Paras?
NOTE CONF
That point to there a buddy the points to there
and the closure.
NOTE CONF
No points too.
Yeah, All right.
NOTE CONF
Cool.
This is how we set ourselves up because now, in
NOTE CONF
this body here.
My access to I is gonna access.
NOTE CONF
I go here and this body here.
Any access to I is that one net.
NOTE CONF
And if I ever do another call to make counter,
there'll be a whole another call over here with a
NOTE CONF
whole separate eye and a whole separate chain pointing back
up to there.
NOTE CONF
Ok, so again, a reminder my style of diagramming is
related to what I'm trying to see.
NOTE CONF
So I've drawn my alphas and Betas a bit differently
this time.
NOTE CONF
Um, because I was including more information, it didn't quite
work.
NOTE CONF
Right?
Uh, this looks just as complicated as before.
NOTE CONF
We talked about as much.
Um but we can see the 123456 We can see
NOTE CONF
the order of visiting.
Um, OK, Once we visit that function, we're done.
NOTE CONF
That's step six.
We don't try and go into it yet.
NOTE CONF
So now number seven will be this one, which is
the return which we haven't talked about yet.
NOTE CONF
What does the return do?
We gotta work out what a return statement does.
NOTE CONF
So we better do the interpreter for return.
Yeah, but as we can guess, if I return an
NOTE CONF
expression, I'd probably go find that expression in the environment.
Well, if it's a variable Sorry.
NOTE CONF
Um, I gotta go find that variable in the environment
and make that my return value.
NOTE CONF
So in this case, I'm gonna look up, count in
the environment.
NOTE CONF
What's the environment at this point?
It's this one.
NOTE CONF
I just added to it.
So I get the count.
NOTE CONF
Lucky.
OK, so if that return line was, say to the
NOTE CONF
left of that function in the abstract, Syntex tree would
break.
NOTE CONF
But because it's to the right of that function, the
seven happens after the six and we're good to go.
NOTE CONF
That's exactly what we expect from the code we saw
because the return count is after the definition of count.
NOTE CONF
That's fine.
OK, but we're seeing our we're seeing it play out
NOTE CONF
in our code in our abstract syntax tree, the code
order playing out and the way it matters questions.
NOTE CONF
Nope.
Alright.
NOTE CONF
Next week is entirely a bug in this mechanism and
how to fix that bug.
NOTE CONF
So we wanna make sure we got this mechanism.
So when we get to next week, we can understand
NOTE CONF
the bug.
He's got his own diagrams that might be perfect for
NOTE CONF
you.
They weren't perfect for me.
NOTE CONF
I had to write my own to actually see the
bug.
NOTE CONF
Um, cool.
But that's why I'm banging on about this as a
NOTE CONF
as a thing to do.
I'm keen to see other people's diagrams.
NOTE CONF
I haven't had the chance cos I'm not in the
workshop classes and nobody's been posting anything online.
NOTE CONF
But if if you ever wanna talk to me through
your diagrams of doing the same thing where you're like
NOTE CONF
I don't think I, I don't know if I really
get this.
NOTE CONF
Just make an appointment.
You can talk to me about your diagram and I
NOTE CONF
can go, Yeah, you got the right idea or no,
that bit didn't make sense.
NOTE CONF
I'm very happy to do that.
OK, let's work out these return statements.
NOTE CONF
Well, let's think ahead.
What do we think a return statement should do?
NOTE CONF
And a place?
No worries.
NOTE CONF
OK, West appearing.
That's perfect.
NOTE CONF
So he says, I need a value to return, and
I need to know the place that I'm gonna return
NOTE CONF
it to, um otherwise rand, a variable a value is
just gonna randomly appear, and that's the key.
NOTE CONF
What's the place so I can generate the value easily
enough.
NOTE CONF
Um, if we look at this example once we're at
that point in the code where the return is generating
NOTE CONF
what count is is easy enough.
It's beta.
NOTE CONF
But where the heck do we send the beta?
That's the question.
NOTE CONF
All right, so we go through each of the steps
again, which we should be happy doing again, cos we
NOTE CONF
need to do them for our assignment, which is not
that far away.
NOTE CONF
And I've got another seven plus questions to answer on
the forum, which I'll probably do later today.
NOTE CONF
Um, we create a return statement.
It's a statement, not an expression.
NOTE CONF
Obviously important.
Remember that a statement does something to the environment or
NOTE CONF
prints something to the screen.
So we can guess.
NOTE CONF
Hm.
We can guess maybe we're gonna go into the environment
NOTE CONF
for this.
Let's see.
NOTE CONF
But the syntax should be fairly easy.
Return word.
NOTE CONF
Colum, You don't have to have an expression in there.
Cos return might just stop the function.
NOTE CONF
So there's actually two things return has to do, right?
It has to find the value to return, but also
NOTE CONF
has to stop any further execution of that function.
So let's keep that in the back of our mind.
NOTE CONF
Uh, so we already said that, you know, languages that
don't in this in this in locks.
NOTE CONF
If, as if expression doesn't return anything, we'll use this
capital.
NOTE CONF
V void.
Where did we use that before?
NOTE CONF
We had expression that sometimes was a value and sometimes
wasn't a value.
NOTE CONF
So it was never a value, but it was still
an expression.
NOTE CONF
We had one of those.
We visited it and it was void.
NOTE CONF
Oh, that's right.
Cos statement we had a visitor needed a return value.
NOTE CONF
Our statements never returned anything.
So we had to put in some return statement for
NOTE CONF
the which was void.
But now with the well, the return is kind of
NOTE CONF
in the middle, right?
A return might have a value.
NOTE CONF
Might not.
Alright, but we've got this capital V void ready for
NOTE CONF
us.
So, um, that's in the interpreter side.
NOTE CONF
But on the lock side, uh, we've actually already got
a special value we could use called nil, so we
NOTE CONF
could consider that result always return something, and that in
the case where we leave out the thing for it
NOTE CONF
to return.
It just returns this lock value nil.
NOTE CONF
And that's quite a neat structure.
And that's really what C does when it uses the
NOTE CONF
void.
Keyword a return with nothing next to it is really
NOTE CONF
a return, giving you a void or the void.
All right, so we we got a special a ST
NOTE CONF
node for it.
Return, I think, obviously.
NOTE CONF
Well, we grabbed the keyword for some unknown reason.
And then we grab whatever we're returning, which might be
NOTE CONF
nil.
Um oh, grabs it so we can use it for
NOTE CONF
error reporting.
OK, and then it's just goes in just like all
NOTE CONF
the rest.
It's a very easy pa, nice and simple.
NOTE CONF
You have to check if you've got a semicolon before
you try and work out.
NOTE CONF
If you're passing an expression, he makes the point here
that if you start passing an expression, it's very hard
NOTE CONF
to work out.
Um, if you when you've stopped because you don't where
NOTE CONF
it's much easier just to look for a return semicolon
and realise that that's the one that doesn't have a
NOTE CONF
return.
If you don't see a return semicolon, then you've got
NOTE CONF
an expression in there.
So go pause.
NOTE CONF
It OK, so you can return from anywhere within the
body of a function even deeply nested inside other statements,
NOTE CONF
it could be inside a loop and an if and
another loop.
NOTE CONF
And remember, back we have started.
We've been exploring the fact that, um, when you're returning
NOTE CONF
backup a call chain, you can use returns.
But when you're jumping from one part of the code
NOTE CONF
up, you have to use exceptions in Java.
Those are the language mechanisms.
NOTE CONF
So we might be thinking at this point, this sounds
like an exception problem.
NOTE CONF
Because if I'm inside a interpret the F, interpret the
loop, interpret the if, and I see a return and
NOTE CONF
I go just return I'm not just returning out of
the If I need to return it out of the
NOTE CONF
If and the loop and the F and the loop,
I gotta return all the way back up to where
NOTE CONF
I last saw a function declaration or a function code.
Yep.
NOTE CONF
So here's the example.
Right.
NOTE CONF
So when we're in this one I visited Ah, I'm
going, It's upside down.
NOTE CONF
I visited a call expression for the count, so I
called its call that required me to execute the block.
NOTE CONF
Visit the while statement.
Visit the block inside the while, execute the block inside
NOTE CONF
the while visit the if statement, visit the return statement.
And at the point where I get here, I wanna
NOTE CONF
force execution to jump all the way back here.
Um, so I could I could carefully organise it so
NOTE CONF
that each of these visit statements was paying attention and
knew when it just had to turf off to the
NOTE CONF
next one.
Or I could use exceptions because that's what they're there
NOTE CONF
for.
When I see a return, I wanna throw a return,
NOTE CONF
and I'm gonna have a try way back when.
And that's gonna catch the return, OK?
NOTE CONF
Visiting a return, Throw a return.
Um, this is a new type.
NOTE CONF
So when I say throw a new return, that means
this this is a new type of, um, runtime exception.
NOTE CONF
I just made up a new runtime exception, so I
better define it.
NOTE CONF
We're in Java.
So this is how we define runtime exceptions by choosing
NOTE CONF
runtime exception where choosing not to have to, uh, check
those exceptions.
NOTE CONF
You know, in Java there's a separate group called runtime
Exceptions that don't get checked.
NOTE CONF
All I'm doing.
I could just throw a runtime exception here if I
NOTE CONF
wanted, but then I wouldn't be able to include the
value that I was returning.
NOTE CONF
So by making my own special type of runtime exception,
I can throw the exception and grab the value that
NOTE CONF
I'm throwing back up the call stack.
And so all I need there is to make sure
NOTE CONF
that this point or one of these two points is
the place where I'm gonna have the catch block.
NOTE CONF
Correct?
Correct.
NOTE CONF
So there it is.
Back over in locks function.
NOTE CONF
When we were executing the body, the entire body, we
just put that in a trat so that if ever
NOTE CONF
a return appears out of the body, we're gonna grab
it at this point and, well, we can grab the
NOTE CONF
return value.
And guess what?
NOTE CONF
We're a function call lock Function.co is a function call.
We just grabbed the value that the locks return emitted.
NOTE CONF
So I'm just gonna use Java's return to send it
back to where it came from.
NOTE CONF
No fancy environment tricks don't need to store a place
for it to go.
NOTE CONF
I just someone called my dot call method.
I'll just send them back the value using Java's mechanism?
NOTE CONF
Yep, yeah, exactly.
And we're reusing Java's return in the same way that
NOTE CONF
we were reusing Java's looping when we did the wild
locks wire statement.
NOTE CONF
It just turned into a Java wire statement.
The locks return turns into a Java return, but we
NOTE CONF
do have to add the ex The exceptions to make
sure the return is filtering exactly to the point we
NOTE CONF
want.
Yeah, And so then the only trick is to make
NOTE CONF
sure that there's somewhere for it to go when it
gets back there.
NOTE CONF
Right, Well, let's go look where we were calling locks
call.
NOTE CONF
Maybe I'll do it on my code.
So this is locks.
NOTE CONF
Callable dot call is the thing that's returning it.
So let me check my locks.
NOTE CONF
Callable for a week, a week?
10.
NOTE CONF
0, 11.
We're week 11 now, right?
NOTE CONF
Yes.
I've got to jump over the week 11.
NOTE CONF
I completely lose track of the week.
OK, so my locks callable here should have the answer.
NOTE CONF
Oh, that's the interface Locks callable.
Sorry, my locks function, which is my implementation of it.
NOTE CONF
There you go.
So I've got the try catch block and I return
NOTE CONF
the value.
Uh, and if there was never a try catch, no
NOTE CONF
return ever happened.
I'm gonna return null from coal.
NOTE CONF
Um So where does this get run?
Well, that was in the visit function.
NOTE CONF
Coal, wasn't it?
Yes.
NOTE CONF
So I go back to my interpreter.
H I There you are.
NOTE CONF
And they look for a visit.
Call expression.
NOTE CONF
There it is.
There you go.
NOTE CONF
Look, the visit call expression is an expression.
And because it's an expression in locks, I'm already calculating
NOTE CONF
a value for it and returning it.
When I wrote that, I probably didn't think Why have
NOTE CONF
I got return function dot call here instead of just
function dot call Or maybe, just maybe, the book talks
NOTE CONF
about it.
But again, this isn't the call is an expression.
NOTE CONF
So all my machinery is set up to expect the
value just to pop out, and I can send it
NOTE CONF
back.
So I do that again.
NOTE CONF
There it goes, and it becomes the it becomes the
object in the visit call.
NOTE CONF
So if it's on the right hand side of an
equals, that's where it gets treated.
NOTE CONF
If it's in a parameter spot, that's how it gets
treated It's just an expression.
NOTE CONF
All right, So the key being the return sits inside
that function definition, which is a statement.
NOTE CONF
But by the time that return is being called, it's
inside a function call, which is an expression, and all
NOTE CONF
the machinery is good to go.
Good to go there.
NOTE CONF
That was nice and easy.
Function returns.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, So maybe we'll have a quick look on our
example then, to think about how that works.
NOTE CONF
D.
Alright, So I'm on step seven where I need to
NOTE CONF
return the variable count on my execution of this.
So under the new system, the locks callable.
NOTE CONF
Well, let's let's remember where we're at.
Um, we've finished with beta, so beta got defined and
NOTE CONF
put over here in the environment.
So we finished with that beta.
NOTE CONF
That was 0.6 and we've moved on to 0.7 or
step seven, which was return to variable count, which was
NOTE CONF
happening in that environment.
So step eight is gonna be evaluate the variable count,
NOTE CONF
and that is gonna end up being beta because whenever
you evaluate a expression, you just go looking in the
NOTE CONF
environment a variable.
You just go looking in the environment for it.
NOTE CONF
So that's beta.
That's going back up there now, under this new system,
NOTE CONF
we're currently inside a call to Alpha, aren't we?
No.
NOTE CONF
Yes.
No.
NOTE CONF
Stop.
Think.
NOTE CONF
Oh, yeah.
We We're inside a call to make counter.
NOTE CONF
So we're inside a call to Alpha at this point.
And so because we're inside a call to Alpha, we've
NOTE CONF
called the call method on this point of the code,
and the new change we just made is we put
NOTE CONF
a try, catch block there.
So any exceptions are gonna stop there, and we've just
NOTE CONF
added the return statement to just throw an exception.
So it throws an exception with a beta in it.
NOTE CONF
Think of it as a little box with a beta
in it throws it up until it hits the the
NOTE CONF
catch block.
And the catch book unpacks the beta.
NOTE CONF
It sends it back.
Well, it doesn't send it quite back that way.
NOTE CONF
Does it?
Because this call came from all where we are.
NOTE CONF
So that's where the beta gets sent back to.
And I made a mistake in my abstract syntax tree,
NOTE CONF
which is now obvious.
What?
NOTE CONF
My mistake?
Hm?
NOTE CONF
Yes.
It should be a vertical see over here.
NOTE CONF
V count equals make counter, and I just wrote call,
Make counter that part of the abstract syntax tree was
NOTE CONF
actually a V Deco with count.
Sorry.
NOTE CONF
Well, always with count on the left and the core
on the right.
NOTE CONF
So now that Beta's come back there later comes back
here as well.
NOTE CONF
And whenever you go to VI Deco, what does that
cause that causes you to add into your current environment?
NOTE CONF
Be up.
OK, that's kind of cool.
NOTE CONF
So now our beta has migrated from the inner environment,
which stops existing once we get outside to the outer
NOTE CONF
environment where we can, um, use it and notice also
that when we call beta later on, this environment's still
NOTE CONF
there.
Because, see, we said that Beta's closure Beta's closure includes
NOTE CONF
this.
So on the call to beta, this environment magic is
NOTE CONF
suddenly available.
So I guess that's why the word closure gets used.
NOTE CONF
And why people think it's magical is because I defined
something down here, which was this I the eye Well,
NOTE CONF
I didn't find it over there.
The I really only existed in this sub environment that
NOTE CONF
was within a function declaration.
And once I get back out of that function declaration.
NOTE CONF
That eye is gone.
That's what we see up there.
NOTE CONF
There's no eye up there.
So from a global place I should be missing.
NOTE CONF
But by returning something, this beta that knew about the
closure all the way up here in the global scope
NOTE CONF
I is still accessible as long as I'm going through
the beta.
NOTE CONF
And so it's as if Beta has closed over that
part of the tree and kept it from disappearing and,
NOTE CONF
you know, kept a reference to it off somewhere else.
But really, it's just this mechanical thing.
NOTE CONF
That's the obvious thing that you should do semantically.
I think it's the obvious thing to do.
NOTE CONF
It's only internally in the compiler or the interpreter that
something has to happen to make it work.
NOTE CONF
And you have to be careful to make sure it
works the way you want it to, which we're gonna
NOTE CONF
see next week.
It doesn't necessarily work the way you want it to.
NOTE CONF
OK, please.
Uh uh, Maybe I'll offer a prize for anyone who
NOTE CONF
posts the best, um, diagram of their own.
Trying to understand this concept to the forums.
NOTE CONF
Yes, I will.
So please make your own diagrams.
NOTE CONF
Maybe of this example.
It's not a bad one.
NOTE CONF
Um, it nests a little bit deep because you've got
to count.
NOTE CONF
No, this one doesn't nest too deep.
This one's a good E.
NOTE CONF
Good one.
To do the the example on and a fun example
NOTE CONF
to do as well is to do another V.
Other count equals make counter and watch what happens in
NOTE CONF
your trace.
Uh, what you should see is, you know, a copy
NOTE CONF
of this alpha section here that's entirely separate with its
own eye, and then you should eventually see other count
NOTE CONF
up there with a gamma or whatever that's closing over
a completely different version of I.
NOTE CONF
OK, so a reminder for I mean, I've banged on
about it before, but for studying this course, um, we're
NOTE CONF
at the pointy end of big, complicated tree traversals with
lots of stuff going on.
NOTE CONF
That's a primary outcome of this course, being able to
do big, complicated tree traversals with lots going on.
NOTE CONF
Don't just try to memorise the concepts.
Don't just try to memorise the examples the whole reason
NOTE CONF
we're bothering to teach you this.
Well, ha, maybe 40% of the re the reason we're
NOTE CONF
bothering to teach you.
This is so that you become skilled at working with
NOTE CONF
big, complicated truths with lots of stuff going on.
Now, when you write that down in a learning outcome,
NOTE CONF
some learning designer comes and tells you that doesn't sound
like a learning outcome.
NOTE CONF
And so you rewrite it.
As you know, you can trace an example with nested
NOTE CONF
function calls.
But really my message to you working with big, complicated
NOTE CONF
tree, uh, trees with lots going on.
Alright, so that shall do us for today.
NOTE CONF
Thank you very much.
And I look forward to seeing the Simon's coming in
NOTE CONF
over the weekend, I suppose.
Yeah.
NOTE CONF
Uh, any other questions?
Sorry.
NOTE CONF
Before we disappear, No, I'll just check online for any
others as well is about You have 10 minutes.
NOTE CONF
Yeah.
Cool.
NOTE CONF
I'm stuck here because some someone might come to do
their exam, but
NOTE CONF